[Music]
I started that I started the beginning
of the class three months ago talking to
you about what it what the problem was
that I was trying to address and the
fundamental problem was the problem of
belief systems and the issue is was what
precisely constitutes a belief system
and then a secondary question was why
are people so inclined to even engage in
conflict to maintain and expand their
belief systems and then maybe a sub
question of that and is there an
alternative to conflict with regards to
belief systems and then the last issue
was something like well is there a way
of judging the relative quality of
belief systems and so those are all very
very complicated questions I mean the
first one is something like how is it
possible to understand the structures by
which we orient ourselves in the world
the second one is something like what's
the psychological significance precisely
of those systems what role does it play
in psychological health and maybe also
in social health the next one is can you
make a non relativistic case when you
assess an array of different value
systems and then link to that is is it
possible to hierarchically organized
value systems in the manner that's
justifiable so that something can be
reasonably considered in a superior or
subordinate position now the last
question drew my attention because
because of the implications of the first
set and the last question drew my
attention because
I was trying to sort out the metaphysics
in some sense of the Cold War the
question was was this just a
battleground between two hypothetically
equally appropriate belief systems which
would could be a morally immoral
relativistic perspective right it's
belief systems are arbitrary and so
combat between them is in some sense
inevitable and even more to the point
there isn't any other way around the
discontinuity in some sense other than
combat or subordination because there's
no way of adjudicating a victor because
there's no such thing as victory if
there's no way of ranking value systems
it's arbitrary as a frightening prospect
because it means that if you have a
value system and I have a value system
and they're different and they're
different I mean we can talk or you can
subordinate yourself or I could do the
same but there's also no reason why we
shouldn't just engage in flat-out
conflict now it's complicated in the
modern world obviously by the fact that
conflict can become so untraveled that
it risks destroying everything and that
doesn't seem necessarily to be in
anyone's best interest unless your
interest haps happens to be in
destroying everything and certainly
there are no shortage of people whose
interests tilt in that direction alright
so the first question was well what does
it mean to have a belief system and
that's a very complicated problem and I
think it's a subset of the question of
being maybe you can break the question
of being into two domains which we've
done in this class and you could say
well you can assess being from the
perspective of what exists and then you
can assess being from the perspective of
how you ought to act so it's like you
walk into a room and you can describe
the furniture or you can determine how
your
going to conduct yourself in the room
maybe it's the difference between a play
and the stage setting for a play now the
modernist perspectives roughly speaking
is that the fundamental reality is to be
found in the description of the
furniture so to speak in the description
of what is that's the scientific process
and the scientific process seems to
involve the stripping off of the
subjective from perception and to some
degree from action and the extraction of
the commonalities across perception as a
means of delineating the nature of
reality
now obviously that's a very powerful
process and it has many advantages but
exactly what it is that science is doing
is not precisely clear one perspective
might be is that we are genuinely
discovering the nature of objective
reality and perhaps even the nature of
reality itself
but there are some problems with that
perspective one of them being that the
scientific process seems to strip the
subjective from the phenomena it does
that technically right I mean you have a
hypothesis about what something is and
you have a hypothesis about what
something is and you have a hypothesis
about some what something is and we
undertake a number of procedures to
assess what the fundamental phenomena is
and then we look across our perceptual
set and we extract out the commonalities
and we dispense with everything that is
superfluous everything that's merely
subjective so what you feel about the
chair is not relevant to the objective
existence of the chair and so it
eradicate subjectivity and that's a very
useful process because it does seem to
enable us to grasp reality in a
fundamental sense more profoundly but it
leaves the subjective behind and maybe
that's a problem
because it annoys okay okay thank you
what if I just didn't alright appreciate
it so so then the issue might be well is
something you retrieve ibly lost if you
dispense with this objective and and
also how deep a hole do you dig when you
dispense with this objective and I think
that that's intrinsically associated
with the problem of the relationship
between is an dot because that's an old
philosophical conundrum
I think first put forth by D David Hume
who made the claim that no matter how
much you know about something from an
empirical perspective you cannot use
that as an unerring guide to action in
relationship to that to that empirical
object or set of empirical objects and
people it's a tricky issue you know
because obviously you can use empirical
information to inform your decisions but
I think but the problem is is that
there's multiple pathways of action that
are implied by any set of data that
seems to be the fundamental problem it's
something like that is that you can't
draw a one-to-one specification between
the empirical district description and
what you should do about that and like
maybe an example is but you can gather a
lot of information about AIDS and you
can gather a lot of information about
cancer and you can gather a lot of
information about educational outcomes
and economic outcomes and so forth but
it isn't obvious how you then use that
empirical information for example how to
guide policy decisions because you might
say well how much money should we spend
on education compared to cancer
prevention and how much money should be
spent on cancer prevention compared to
curing aids and or addressing disease in
the third-world country what happens is
that the set of variables that you
encounter while trying to make your
empirical calculation get to be so
massive so rapidly that there doesn't
seem to be any logical way of linking
them to a behavioral outcome now it's
kind of associated with the postmodern
conundrum as well which is well if you
have a set of data and it
could be a literary work without better
there's a very large number of
interpretations that you can derive from
that set of data and there's no simple
way of deciding which one is going to be
canonical and so it isn't it I think the
reason that you can't derive a naught
from an is is because you run into
something like combinatorial explosion
it's like you have an infinite number of
facts at your disposal roughly speaking
and then another infinite number of ways
that you can organize those facts and
that massive array of facts and and
andrey categorized facts doesn't tell
you what to do in a given situation and
so maybe the question of what to do in a
given situation is a different domain of
question and I believe that to be the
case I think it was Stephen Jay Gould
who talked about religion and science as
- I think he called them different
Magisterium to different fundamental
domains that and that each had their
realm of operation and one was the
description of the objective world
obviously that's on the scientific end
and the other was the realm of ethics
and so you could put religion mythology
narrative the humanities all of that
history even for that matter to some
degree into the into the ethics category
and because I don't see a
straightforward way of taking a set of
facts and then transforming them into a
behavioral compulsion then I do think
that these two things are reasonably
regarded as overlapping and
intrinsically associated but but
technically and philosophically
separable alright so then then the next
question emerges well if they're
separable if there has to be a domain of
inquiry into the structure of values
what might that look like
like how is it that you would understand
the psychological and sociological
phenomena that are associated with a
moral stance
howhow would you understand the details
of that and then even more to the point
is there any way of subjecting different
sets of ethical interpretation to
testing so that you can judge their
comparative validity because that's sort
of the way out of moral relativism
roughly speaking it's like first you
make the proposition that there are
value structures and that they're
independent from empirical investigation
and then the next is that you
investigate the possibility that you can
compare and contrast different
structures of ethics and draw some sort
of conclusion that's not merely
arbitrary now it might be Turtles all
the way down that's how the old joke
goes right but but maybe not then I was
interested in that again because I
thought well are we fighting the Cold
War merely because we're having an
argument or is there some manner in
which one of these systems can be just
determined to be wrong and of course
there was more weight behind that query
because the Soviet system and the Maoist
system and and the system that's in
place in North Korea were not only
predicated on different assumptions than
in the Western system but they were also
extraordinarily murderous and so that
seemed to add additional weight to the
to the sequence of questions so
I was reading young at the time and
young was Carl young was fundamentally I
would say a psychologist of narrative of
story and and he he outlined this he
outlined the idea for me that people
inhabited stories roughly speaking he
said actually they inhabited myths and
even more to the point whether they knew
it or not they inhabited archetypal
myths or even that they were possessed
by them and so it was the first time I'd
really come into contact with the idea
directly put that there was a direct
relationship between the structures that
you use to orient yourself in the world
and stories and so then I started to
assess the fundamental elements of
stories what what - story looked like
and while I was doing that that was
informed by a number of other things
that I was reading about including a set
of I read the neuroscience literature
with regards to information processing
fairly extensively and that introduced
me into a whole set of other ideas
including cybernetic ideas which have
been incorporated into what I was
describing to you and this basic
cybernetic system is a system that has a
starting point in a system that has an
endpoint and a system that has a
subsystem that monitors progress or
deviation from progress along the
pathway to the endpoint and I thought
well that looks a lot like a story or a
map that's another way of thinking about
it and I thought okay well that's where
the overlap is and the fundamental story
is something like it's very
straightforward it's it's also the frame
that you inhabit when you conceptualize
the world and narrow and narrow and
simplify the world which you have to do
because it's so complex because you have
this infinite number of facts that are
laying around you well so what are you
doing well you're a mobile creature a
living creature not a static information
processor and you're targeted you're a
targeted creature and otherwise you
wouldn't move right to move is to be a
targeted creature because you have to
move towards something or away from
something so the targeting is built
right into the fact that you're a mobile
creature and then you might say well
what do you target and answer to that is
well you target
target you could say you target what you
aim for but then you could say well you
you aim for what you want you target
your desires and then that leads you
into a discussion of the underlying
neurobiology essentially you bring to
the table
a set of inbuilt desires and the targets
that you pick have to address the fact
that those desires exist and the desires
are actually grounded in necessity and
this is this is a sidebar but this is
where I think Piaget theory is weaker
than it should be because Piaget and you
know I'm a great admirer of Piaget
believed that the human infant came into
the world with a fairly primordial set
of reflexes mostly sensory motor
reflexes and then bootstrapped him or
herself up on the basis of those
reflexes in the sociological in the
social surroundings viewpoint that the
child comes in with a few basic elements
that can get it going elements of
exploration and memory essentially and
then it builds itself of the consequence
of its exploration in the social
community now I think that's true except
that it's too empty because what it
fails to take into consideration is the
fact that and I think this is this is an
observation in some sense
philosophically that was first made by
Immanuel Kant when he criticized Pure
Reason so that you can't come into the
world structureless you have to come
into the world with an inbuilt structure
and then it's the interaction of that
structure with the world that provides
the information that you can use to
build yourself but the structure has to
be there and I would say that's the
sameness logically speaking as the idea
that the Great Father is always there
right there's the great mother is always
there that's chaos itself the great
father is always there that's order
that's the interpretive structure that
you use to interact with the chaos and
then of course the individual is always
there at the same time that Piaget in
some sense ree-ree told that story
except he didn't give enough credence to
the fact that the infant comes into the
world far more fully formed than his
theory
his theory presumes now the problem see
that the problem with that is that
without that additional underlying set
of let's call them neurobiological
constraints the interpretation universe
gets too large you need constraints to
narrow the domain of phenomena that
you're contending with and and it's in
the analysis of the constraints that the
answer to how do you stop drowning in an
infinite number of potential
interpretations emerges the
interpretations are subject to
constraints and that's also the way out
of the moral relativist paradox as far
as I can tell now one of the things I
really liked about Piaget was that he
describes some of the constraints one of
the constraints was is well if I'm going
to exist in a social world and I'm going
to because I won't exist at all if I
don't exist in a social world then there
are constraints on the way that I have
to interact with other people and Piaget
is essential point was I have to
organize myself to play a joint game
with you but the joint game has
constraints and one of them is you have
to want to play because you have other
options and then there are other
constraints you and I have to be able to
play in a way that other people don't
object to or maybe even that you and I
have to play in a way that other people
will be look support and then you can
imagine another constraint which is you
and I have to play a game in a way that
other people would support that will
last more than the moment so it has it
has to work today and tomorrow and next
week it has to work across the span of
times it has to work not only for you
and I but it has to work for our future
cells and so the damn constraints are
starting to pile up that's just on the
socio-cultural side that's on the
constructionist side only but there's
about the biological constraints are
equally important because not only does
the game that you and I have to play
have to satisfy those emergent
sociological constraints but the game
also has to be organized so that the
internal polity that that's composed of
let's call them the fundamental
motivational and emotional systems that
make that constitute us they have to all
find satisfaction because otherwise the
system grounds
halt and so this seems to me to be the
beginnings of an answer to the
postmodern conundrum looks like okay any
set of facts is amenable to an infinite
number of interpretations fine
got it that makes deriving and is from
an oauth2 very difficult endeavor right
no problem all right but that doesn't
mean that any old solution will work why
well first of all it's merely because we
introduced work into the conversation to
begin with the interpretation has to be
functional and again that's what it
seems that's what seems to tie it back
to the story this is also what got me
interested in pragmatism technically
speaking and so because if if your
conundrum is here you are and there you
have to be and how to get there then one
of the constraints on the manner in
which you interpret the world is when
you apply your interpretation do you end
up moving from the point you're at to
the point you want to be and if the
answer that is no then the solution is
insufficient now you could call the
solution untrue but I it's dangerous too
to introduce the truth falsity dilemma
because because it isn't its
functionality more its functionality
more than truth although I think you
could say that in the final analysis
truth is integrally linked to function
but I'm not going to touch that question
for the time being the point is is that
your interpretation of the world carries
within it implicitly a theory about its
own validity and the theory about its
own validity is that if you enacted in
the world it will produce the result
that you desire and then the consequence
of that is that if it doesn't produce
the result that you desire then it isn't
good enough theory period and that's how
you grapple with the fact that although
you don't know everything you still have
to orient yourself in the world you lay
out partial theories that make partial
predictions and if they do a good enough
job then you don't worry about it any
more and you go on to the next thing
okay so then you think there's a lot of
constraints piling up on your
interpretations number one they have to
work for the creature that you are and
so you know we can lay it sort of like
Maslow's hierarchy of needs something
like that's not exactly the same
because I don't think that he got the
hierarchy right for for very complex
reasons but it's it's reasonably obvious
to to observe that well you're not going
to work out very well if you don't have
anything to eat and you know you've got
about a week in you if you don't have
anything to drink and obviously you need
shelter and you know you need you need
companionship and by need what I mean is
that if you don't have these things then
you die the whole game comes to a halt
so we can ground that in self-evident
reality without any real problem and you
might say well what's the list of human
necessities and that that's that's a
difficult thing to parameterize because
you can argue about the degree to which
something is necessary but there's some
things that we know about well we
covered the basics temperature
regulation elimination food intake
shelter right but then there's more
subtle things like well children for
example died without touch so there's
there's something integral about tactile
interaction with other people so we
could call that love if you want to do
that it's not optional right play is the
same thing
children do not develop properly unless
they play and I would say that adults
also can't maintain their mental health
or physical health unless they play too
and so you can say well there's a core
set of necessities and then off of that
there's a secondary set of like what
would you call them their own ultimate
necessities but they're pretty hot
they're going to be pretty highly valued
by people and more or less universally
pain avoidance for example under most
circumstances most people don't really
like to be in terror most people really
don't like to be disgusted you know you
can lay out the basic emotions you can
lay out the basic motivations and you
can say well the game that you're going
to play has to operate within a space
that's defined by that set of a priori
constraints fine now things are getting
pretty constrained here so they had the
game you play house to satisfy that set
of biological demands intrinsic
biological demands and it has to be
something that you can utilize with
other people voluntarily and it has to
be something that will be playable
across
multiple iterations and I would say
there's a very limited number of
interpretive interpretive structures
that are going to satisfy all of those
preconditions simultaneously and to me
that just blows out the two things it
blows out the claims of moral relativism
and it it it also demolishes and this is
the same thing in some sense it
demolishes this ideas that the manner in
which people organize themselves in the
world as individuals and in societies is
somehow arbitrary doesn't look to me to
be arbitrary at all and so in ampere
days genius I think in some part was
observing that in children spontaneously
in that when children passed the
egocentric phase which means after
they're about two years of old old
they're maybe they're what they're
approaching three years old they've more
or less got their internal mechanisms
organized so that there are unitary
being roughly speaking at three they
start to develop the ability to use
fictional frames of reference so and
that's an interesting thing because I
would say that the fundamental
biological systems come armed with their
own frame of reference so if you're
hungry poof up comes a frame of
reference and within that your
perceptions are shaped the action
proclivities are are primed and the
world lays itself out around that
particular biological necessity and you
can lay those out same if you're thirsty
same if you're too hot same if you want
to play all those systems come built in
but then the problem with that is that
they compete because it isn't obvious
which one should take priority and then
it's not that easy to organize them in a
social space and so what seems to have
happened to human beings is that we've
been able to replace the frame that's
predicated on motivational necessity
with abstracted frames that are more
voluntary voluntarily constructed that
incorporate multiple motivational
systems simultaneously and that's in
some sense that's also what it's the
same thing as we learned how to think
abstractly and so the frame
that you're going to lay out on the
world if it's a good frame is one that
solves a whole set of problems at the
same time and so that and you can slot
different frames you can you can
experiment with different frames and
that's a precondition to being able to
play because one of the things that
Piaget pointed out you can see this when
children pretend play it's like four and
even more clearly in games that have
rules but let's say they're there in
pretend play and they're going to say
well we're going to lay out a little
fictional schema here we're going to
play house and you can be the cat and
all be the I'll be the dad and then you
negotiate a bit to see if those rules
are acceptable and then you run it as a
simulation and that's what kids are
doing when they're playing and they're
experimenting with different
superordinate
frames of reference that are active all
in the world and they're in there
they're learning how to develop those
perceptual schemes and also how to
interact in a manner that allows the
scheme that they're using to find its
social acceptability and its successful
the child assumes that the scheme is
successful if both children have fun
while they're doing it and so that's the
volunteerism and so Piaget made a very
interesting point about that that I
think is absolutely brilliant he said
that there's a difference between a game
that people will play voluntarily and
one that has to be enforced and so then
you can imagine an environment where
game a is played voluntarily it has a
certain end and game B is played by
force but both of them are moving
towards the same end and Piaget his
claim was the game that's played
voluntarily or even more to the point
the set of all games that are played
voluntarily will out-compete the set of
all games that are played by force if
they're put head-to-head in a
competitive environment
I thought god that's such a brilliant
observation because there you have the
basis for a pragmatic grounding of for
the evaluation of ethics it's like you
can pick the target it doesn't matter
whatever target you pick if the game is
voluntary and aimed at the target it
will defeat a game that's imposed by
tyranny now it's a proposition but it's
a pretty good proposition and I would
say there's a fair bit of evidence for
this proposition and a fair bit of it is
actually
derived from observation of animal
behavior because I ran you guys through
the emerging literature on the stability
say of chimpanzee hierarchies and the
chimpanzee tyrant hierarchy isn't very
stable and the reason for that is that
to subordinate chimps who are 3/4 as
strong as the dominant tyrant can take
them out and they do and so then the
question might be well how do you have
to conduct yourself as a high dominance
chimp
if you're not going to be torn apart by
those who are hypothetically your
subordinates and the answer to that is
well don't be too much of a tyrant
formulate some social connections engage
in some reciprocity with regards to your
social relationships don't oppress the
females don't torment the children
it said etc because that makes you
unpopular and then you'll get torn to
shreds and so there are practical limits
on the expression of tyranny that are a
consequence both of biological
limitations because people are going to
object if the system is set up so that
their fundamental needs are met and
they're also going to object if the game
that's being played isn't functioning
socially and so this is very very tight
set of constraints and then the question
might be okay if you take that set of
constraints what sort of systems can
operate what would you say
well just that what set of systems can
operate within those sets of constraints
then you might say if you take that the
set of all systems that might operate
within those constraints and you look at
what's common across them then you could
extract out what's essentially a
universal morality it's something like
that and I don't see how that
proposition is precisely questionable it
seems to me that all of that's built on
rock like there's no doubt that infants
bring biological necessity to the table
I think that's fully established and
it's established physiologically it's
established behaviorally it's
established with regards to evolutionary
history because we can take the
motivational systems that are part and
parcel of our being and we can trace
their development back in some cases
half a billion years so
so the idea that the the infant is a
blank slate when it's born and that's
subject to infinite sociological
manipulation is a it's a dead in the
water
that's just not the case so okay so far
so we've got that nailed down hard and
then the idea that your identity is also
shaped sociologically well I don't think
anybody disputes that it doesn't matter
where they are on the interpretative
framework they might dispute the degree
to which that occurs and the mechanisms
by which it occurs but the fact that it
occurs that's that's close enough to
self evidence so we can just leave it
there well then the question is what are
the consequences of the sociological of
socio of socialization and once you
admit the Nifty existence of the realm
of biological necessity you instantly
put a set of constraints on how
societies can structure themselves so
that they will not be torn down and
overthrown well that if you look at how
kids are socialized I think that psays
developmental observations are bi and bi
correct the first two years it's mostly
interactions between the infant and the
parents it's it's bi-directional though
because the infant has to come to terms
with the mother but the mother also has
to come to terms with the infant so it's
not even top-down at the level of infant
maternal relationship quite the contrary
and if you watch a new mother adapt to a
baby you can see that the mother is
doing as much out apt ation to the baby
as the baby is to the mother because the
infant has this inbuilt character
already and has to be charmed into a
relationship that's love does that and
and attention it's very little different
than establishing a relationship with
someone who's older it's it's lower
resolution and it's harder to make the
observations because of course the
infant is only capable of behavioral
display can't can't speak but
nonetheless the necessity for
establishing the individual relationship
is there to begin with so even in the
early stages of the infant's
realization the process isn't state
downward it's not great farther down
work it's mutual and then of course by
the time the child is old enough to be
launched out into the social world then
all the constraints that are associated
with the playground are immediately
placed on that child and that's a very
unforgiving landscape right because the
last thing a child wants really the last
thing a child wants is not to have any
friends or even perhaps equally
seriously not to have a best friend I
read something so idiotic the other day
that I couldn't believe it so the newest
Prince so queen elizabeth's I guess
great grandchild is off to daycare in in
the UK and in this daycare they don't
let the kids have best friends because
that's unfair I thought you know
something times you see something that's
so stupid you can't even believe it
it exists and that was one of those
examples because it's been known for
quite a long time that one of the
developmental milestones the children
attained somewhere between say the age
of five and ten is they pick a best
friend and so they and and you know the
hypothesis well that's unfair to all the
other children it's like well first of
all you can't be the best friend to
everyone because you didn't maybe
there's a billion children so each of
them gets one second it's like that's
just not a very deep relationship so the
idea that you can be equally friendly
with everyone is it's a preposterous but
even worse the thing is the thing that
the child is doing is actually becoming
there they're stepping out of their
egocentricity because their best friend
becomes more important than they are and
that's a precursor for adult
relationships where you know if you're
married well your your partner should be
at least as important as you are and the
relationship should be more important
but then when you have children it's
like they're more important than you
that that's that it's unless there's
something wrong with you you come second
and your children come first and their
way first they're not just a little
buddy you're necessary because without
you they're not going to manage so you
have to take care of yourself but you're
not number one anymore once you have
kids unless seriously unless you didn't
learn the lessons in the playground and
when you have a best friend you're not
number one they are and so
so anyways there are these constraints
that emerge in in the social landscape
you have to have friends and also you
have to single someone out as
particularly unique among those friends
and establish a genuinely reciprocal and
caring relationship I can't remember the
psychiatrist who studied this so
intently unfortunately he was the first
person to to do a detailed analysis of
the best friend relationships that
children established and I'd like to
give him credit for his ideas but
unfortunately I can't remember his name
so okay so what are the propositions so
far you inhabit a structure the dorian
CU in the world it has something that's
akin to a narrative structure i'm here
i'm going there and this is the way i
did it its narrative if you describe it
it's based in biological necessity but
it's shaped by social socialization and
the fact of that base and that shaping
means that the set of interpretive
schema that you can lay out in the world
are bounded those would be functional
hypothetically functional systems and
maybe they compete over over the
evolutionary time span but there's
something in common across that set of
functional interpretations and if you
extract that out you can get the initial
images of what you might describe as an
archetype you never Cilmi that's what
archetypes are fundamentally so and to
say all that is no more than to say that
people can extract across instances and
we can obviously do that so then the
question is can you start to develop an
articulated picture of what that
archetypal structure of universal
morality might be and so my answer to
that was basically well let's look at
old stories as many old stories as we
can collect and if their stories are
stories that have survived for a very
long period of time so much the better
because it that indicates that they're
acutely memorable and peculiarly
functional
because if they weren't memorable then
they'd have been forgotten and if they
weren't functional they wouldn't have
managed to be the foundation stories for
four cultures that lasted for thousands
or even tens of thousands of years so
and then we could say well let's collect
a whole variety of these stories and see
if there's patterns across them now the
danger that is have you collected an
unbiased set of stories danger number
one how do you know that you're not just
reading into the stories
that's the postmodern problem reasonable
reasonable objections and so that those
objections have been laid against people
like wrote the Golden Bough Fraser who
is the Fraser who was one of the first
anthropologists to collect stories from
all over the world and to start to look
for commonalities the same objection has
been laid at the feet of people like
Richie le odd or Carl Jung or Joseph
Campbell it's like how do you know you
just how do you know you're not just
cherry-picking your damn interpretations
perfectly reasonable perfectly
reasonable objection and I would say
that the reason I don't believe that I'm
cherry-picking my interpretations is
because I used a method and it's a
method that's akin to the multi trait
multi method method of construction that
that clinical psychology and other
disciplines of psychology rely upon but
it's also akin to a process put forward
by E or Wilson that he called Concilium
sand the process is something like well
pick your level of analysis does the
phenomena manifest itself at that level
of analysis yes
pick another level of analysis and
another level of analysis and another
level of analysis and see if the same
phenomena manifests itself at every
single level and then assume that the
probability that that will happen by
chance decreases with each additional
level of analysis that fits that where
this concordance and I thought okay that
that that makes sense so it isn't only
that you can look for patterns and
stories because you know what if you're
a hyperactive pattern detector which
basically means like there are people
like that people who tilt towards
paranoia people who tilt towards
conspiracy theories you can see it
manifest itself in New Age thinking all
the time because New Age thinkers are
very high in openness but not very good
at critical thinking and so they see
phenomena a and B and C and D they think
pad
then they think universal pattern but
they don't attempt to disconfirm their
pattern prediction and so what I tried
to do when I was starting to see
patterns emerge in the stories
informed by people like dealing in a
leotta and so forth was to see if what
they were describing manifested itself
at any other levels of analysis that
were independent intellectually from
that stream of thinking and I found it
in two places
targeted cybernetics and I found it in
neuroscience and so on and that that and
the neuroscience element that includes
the physiology but also the behavioral
analysis that was done by by people most
particularly like like like jeffrey gray
and and the animal experimental is who
were brilliant brilliant scientists and
who've done a very good job of laying
out the manner in which interpretive
frameworks exist within the realm of
animal cognition and and and to describe
how they manifest themselves in the
world so i thought okay that's not too
bad because we've got maybe four
different levels of evidence all
pointing in the same direction so that's
why i walk you guys through the neural
psychology it's like a story is you're
going somewhere you're somewhere and
you're going somewhere and you're
tracking your progress okay that's the
story well what what happens when you
look at how people lay out their called
cognitive maps well it's the same thing
you specify a target an endpoint you
specify a beginning point which is just
where you are and then there's a
mechanism a comparator mechanism that
operates or multiple comparator
mechanisms that operate neural
physiologically to orient yourself
towards that goal and the emotions
basically emerge as a as a consequence
of that positive emotions indicating
that you're moving forward properly
negative emotions indicating that you've
encountered some kind of obstacle it's
like well that's the basic that's the
basic structure of a narrative okay fine
so now we can see how its instantiated
neural physiologically that adds a fair
bit of credence to the to the entire
process so
now normally when you look at the basic
cybernetic work there's a hypothesis
that the system is oriented towards a
goal and that it's comparing what is
manifesting itself in the world to that
desired end state as the system moves
but it's too simple because people don't
precisely have gold they have nested
hierarchies of goals and so the issue of
emotional regulation becomes more
complex than are you proceeding happily
towards your current goal because your
goal is composed of micro goals and it's
a constituent element of a set of macro
goals and so that makes the problem of
error far more complex than it would be
if you only had one frame of reference
and you were only adjudicating your
error within that frame of reference the
question starts to become what does it
mean when you make a mistake and answer
to that the behavioral answer to that
was well you encounter a stimuli that's
a threat or maybe a punishment or an
incentive reward or a consumer Tori
reward something like that it's very
it's a it's a unit dimensional and
oversimplified answer I'm not
complaining about it has great utility
but there's the problem there's a
problem and the problem is it doesn't
take into account the nested structure
of this of your goal hierarchy and what
that means is that it underestimates the
difficulty of responding to an error
because the problem with an error is
that you don't know what the error
signifies and that's a huge problem and
that's part of what I want to delve into
even in more depth today and so this is
like Ellis and the what in Wonderland
going down the rabbit hole it's exactly
the same thing that's the hole the
rabbit hole is you made a mistake right
you made a mistake you've got your
oversimplified representation of the
world laid upon it it validates itself
in its execution if it executes properly
if it executes improperly then what does
that signify and the answer isn't
precisely that you've made a mistake
the answer is it signifies that there's
something in the world that you excluded
that shouldn't have been excluded and
that's a big problem because when you've
laid out a simplified schema on the
world you've excluded virtually
everything and so what that means is
that as soon as you make an error the
search space for the error immediately
tends towards the infinite and you
experience that it's part of it human
existential experience and the way you
experience that is especially if your
mood is shaky is you lay out a small
plan like maybe you go out for coffee
with someone that you're romantically
interested in and they're there they're
not they're not pleasant to you and and
so that's an error it means well what
does it mean well you've construed
yourself wrong you've construed them
wrong
you've construed the opposite sex wrong
you've construed human beings wrong
you're a walking catastrophe and you
might as well not even exist it's like
well that's that's pretty extreme but
it's not that extreme I'll tell you like
it's not that uncommon for people to
have exactly that set of catastrophic
responses to even a minor setback now
it's not good for them and I would say
you know just because you scraped your
foot doesn't mean you should dig a grave
and jump into it pull the dirt on on top
of you you know so you don't want to
start by taking yourself completely
apart but that doesn't mean people won't
do it they do it all the time in fact to
me it's always a mystery that they don't
do it every single time because the
logical inference for why didn't you get
someone interested in you could easily
be because you're a failure as a human
being and at some level that's actually
true now it's all it's true in a way
that's not that helpful right because
it's just too catastrophic but it isn't
obvious at all how people can defend
themselves against that cascade of a
Kotak catastrophizing I mean after all
if you are everything you could be then
maybe everyone would be attracted to you
I mean perhaps not but you get the point
and no and no easy rationalization is
going to let you just brush that away
especially if you actually happen to be
interested in the person because that's
even worse because then not only are you
rejected but you rejected by someone
who's who upon whom you've projected an
ideal or perhaps on from whom you've
actually observed an ideal so it's worse
you're you're rejected by someone that
you want to have be attractive to you to
validate your old miserable existence
it's a non-trivial problem so you're in
this protected space that I you know I
made an analogy between that in the
Garden of Eden or the city that Buddha
was raised it it's all protected and
everything inside it is beautiful and
functional and that's by definition
because if your frame of reference is
working properly then what's within it
is things you control that are
functional and and and and and they're
serving your purposes so when you're
successful you're in the Garden of Eden
that's one way of thinking about it when
the things that you're laying out in the
world are delivering what they're
supposed to deliver that's what you
inhabit but the problem is is that
there's always a snake inside the garden
and it's that's the story that's echoed
in the story of Buddha in that case it's
Buddha's own curiosity that happens to
be the snake and you could actually say
the same thing about human beings maybe
it wasn't the snake maybe it was Eve's
curiosity they're the same thing in some
sense and so it's Buddha's curiosity
that drives them outside the city to
find disease and death and to blow apart
his paradisal conceptualization of the
world and so when we're looking at unit
for universality the first thing we
might say is well you have a frame of
reference that you've laid on the world
it's a story you live inside a story and
the second thing week it's and that's
universally true the content of the
story can differ that's okay I don't
care about that it's the structural
equivalence that I'm interested in you
live inside the story and you have to
because you have to live in something
like that because you are goal-directed
and you have to be and you have to
simplify the world because there you're
just not enough of you to take into
account everything at once in fact you
can hardly take into account anything at
once so you have to narrow things
unbelievably and by narrowing
and including only certain things you
exclude virtually everything else so
you're always in the problem in the
situation where you have this little
bounded universe that you inhabit but
outside of it is chaos itself and and so
that's the existential landscape order
surrounded by chaos right it's like a
tree it's like the the evolutionary home
of primates the tree with the snakes on
the ground that's that's our landscape
or it's the fire for tribal people and
the terrors of the forest that are
beyond the that would be on the light
that the fire casts it's explored
territory versus unexplored territory
and that's that's an archetype as well
that that you can't not be in a
situation where that's the case even if
you're among friends you know
you think that's explored territory
that's not exactly right because what
happens if you're among friends is that
they carefully reveal new parts of
themselves all the time so it's like
they're blasting little elements of
unexplored territory you territory at
you constantly and if they don't then
what happens you get bored and you look
for new people and we know there's
empirical data on that with regards to
intimate relationships because there was
a nice study done a while back showing
that looking at the ratio of positive to
negative emotional experiences that were
most predictive of long-term
relationship success and the answer was
now obviously it depends on how you
would measure an event and how you would
measure positive and negative emotion
but that aside the finding was something
like if you're in a relationship and you
only have five positive interactions -
one negative interaction then the
relationship will end it's too negative
but if you have more than eleven
positive interactions - one negative
interaction then it also ends and you
think well that's pretty bloody acuter
what why in the world would that be
don't you want like a hundred to one
positive to negative interactions and
answer that is what makes you think that
you want a relationship so that you
could be happy or at least happy moment
to moment why do you
think that it's not it's certainly not
the case as you know that - because you
I mean I bet you there's not a person in
this room who hasn't rejected someone
because they were too nice to them
something like that person's no
challenge it's something like that you
want someone who you know you can get
along with them but now and then they
bite you and you think oh that's that's
interesting you know I didn't really
expect that and then you go and puzzle
over it for a while and you torture
yourself about it and that's one of the
things that keeps you really linked in
to the relationship and the reason for
that is that part of the reason that you
want the relationship isn't so that
you're happy right now
it's so that you can live a high-quality
life across multiple decades and so
you're looking for someone that you have
to contend with who's going to push you
beyond what you already are and who's
going to judge you harshly often for
your limitations now that'll make you
angry and all about you you know and
resentful and maybe you'll take your
revenge and and all of that but you
don't want someone who thinks you're
perfect in your current form partly
because why would you want to go out
with someone that deluded so okay so
you've got this interpretive schema laid
out on the world and it excludes the
entire world and because it excludes the
world the world tends to manifest itself
inside that protected space on a in an
uncontrollable manner and that can take
you down and it takes you down the
rabbit hole and down the rabbit hole is
where everything is because when you
make an error what that is is the
manifestation of the excluded world and
the problem with that is that's too much
right because if you step out of the
lifeboat into the ocean then you drown
and that's that's not any good you can't
drown every time something manifests
itself that you didn't expect
there has to be a mechanism for
orienting you in the face of error all
right so what exactly does that imply
the question is what do you discover
when you go down the rabbit hole
I was thinking about that a lot today I
showed you that diagram that I thought
was like a map of the phenomenological
world the the lowest resolution category
is something like the dragon of chaos
and so you might say well what you
discover when you make an error and the
answer is first it's a brief
manifestation of the dragon of chaos and
that's no more to say then when you
encounter the incursion of unexplored
territory into explored territory the
circuitry you use is the same circuits
that we use to to respond
instantaneously to the presence of
predatory forces we use that circuit and
that makes perfect sense because the
predator is almost by definition the
thing that lurks beyond the safe
confines of the community and I told you
I believe a story about rats raised in
naturalistic environments the rats are
we've got the burrows on one end of the
little field that hierarchy they're
doing their little rat social things
they're playing and they're laughing and
they're tickling each other and they're
there you're you know raising the rat
families and that's all working out just
fine
rats in that situation by the way are
very difficult to get addicted to
cocaine if you want to dick the rat to
cocaine you have to put it in a cage and
isolated it's not really a rat any more
than any more than you're a person if
you're in solitary confinement right I
mean you're sort you're mostly your just
misery anyways in solitary confinement
you'd be after cocaine non-stop and
maybe under other circumstances but like
a normal rat it's not that interested in
cocaine so let's just decide no anyways
the rats are doing their thing and then
they've learned that they can go out to
the other side of the field and they can
get food and so one day the
experimenters instead of putting food
out there put a cat out there and the
rat goes out and gets a whiff of the cat
which they do not like and then the rat
runs home and pokes is because of the
Burrow and screams for like two days
ultrasonic Li and all the other rats are
like frozen stiff because of that
they're not going anywhere
and so a 2-day rat screaming v is no
a trivial thing that's be I calculated
that be the equivalent of use screaming
for two weeks so you have to be pretty
upset to scream for two weeks right so
this is hard on the rat but the reason
I'm telling you this is the rat doesn't
expect the cat to be there the rat goes
out and there's a cat and what it uses
is its predator detection and alert
systems to signify the presence of the
cat and what we've done with the dragon
imagery roughly speaking is make an
amalgam of predatory monsters and state
that's a symbol for what lurks beyond
safety because we're observing our own
responses in some sense and and it's not
only that we're observing our own
responses but we also have a category
categorical set of responses to predator
and we again there's no speculation
about this we already know this like if
you go study monkeys for example they
have distinct sets of vocalization that
are associated with predator detection
that have distinct circuits we know that
there are predator detection circuits
and it's not unreasonable to also
presuppose that they underlie the
phenomena for example that human beings
are very good at learning fear to snakes
snake fear might be innate like that's
pushing the argument but at minimum
psychologists have already concluded
that even if snake fear isn't innate and
it probably is that it can be learned
like that so you can condition people to
be afraid of pictures of snakes way
faster than you can condition them to be
afraid of pictures of electrical outlets
or handguns so and that's well
documented I don't think anybody
disputes that at all so the first
assumption is when something unexpected
emerges so we'll call that the snake in
the garden that your prey and that's a
predator and that the monster has come
to get you it's something like that now
the representation of the dragon is more
complex than mere monster because the
dragon the mythological dragon also is
the thing that hoards treasure and I
really like that symbol I think it's I
think that's also why it will never go
away it's such a great symbol because it
says well the unknown can take you down
it can it can
right you with its fiery breath like
poisonous snake and it can burn things
like fire and it's a aerial predator
that can take you from the air and it's
a carnivorous predator that can take you
from the ground and it's reptilian it's
the sort of thing that can pull you down
into the water and it's easy to see that
as an amalgam of of the threats that
have been laid forth for human beings
since the beginning of time and Monster
is an amalgam of predator and you might
say well there's no such thing as a
dragon it's like yes there is it's just
a loose category what's common across
all Predators equals dragon it's not
like it's a knot they're not real
they're hyper real they're more real
than the phenomena themselves just like
an abstraction can be more real than the
phenomena the result and then the
canonical dragon for human beings isn't
just a predator
we're not rabbits you can imagine that
the dragon for a rabbit is just a dragon
there's no damn treasure there at all
but for human beings its ambivalent
because the thing that you don't know
about is also the thing that holds the
greatest gift and why is that it's
because the unrealized world manifests
itself when you make an error and the
unrealized world is something that can
take you down obviously but it's also
the source of all new information it's
an infinite source of information and
that's a really useful thing to know
error is an infinite source of
information and that's one of the things
that can help you recalibrate the way
that you interact with the world you
think well we're interacting let's say
we're having a conversation and it's
flowing melodically and all of a sudden
I say something and there's a
disjunction right you're offended by it
there's some negative emotion that comes
up or or or or you know maybe I've said
something to impress you or to be
arrogant and you respond badly it's like
we've got this melodic thing going on
it's a consensual frame and something
pokes itself up to put a disjunction in
the conversation it's like well that's
where the information is it's like
something went wrong something didn't
work out I'm not looking at the world
properly or I don't know you well enough
or as well as I thought there's
something there and if I have any sense
I'm going to focus my attention on that
like not obsessively or anything like
that but
where all the information is because as
long as what we're doing is working then
we both know enough already
as soon as what we're doing together
it'll working then that's instant
evidence that there's something about us
that needs to be updated and you might
think well that's a terrible thing and
the answer is yes of course it is it's a
terrible thing but it's also the thing
and this is the next stage of the
development of this let's call it
universal morality it's like the
universal morality might be found in the
answer to the question what should you
do when you make a mistake now one
answer is catastrophic dissolution
that's that's a collapse into chaos
well that's no one is going to pick that
voluntarily let's put it that way that's
it unbelievably unpleasant terribly
anxiety-provoking shameful and painful
all at the same time worse it can mean
the absence of positive emotion because
if you really collapse into chaos not
only are you overwhelmed by negative
emotion but the positive emotion system
shut off and that that's what happens to
someone who's extraordinarily depressed
and also hyper anxious at the same time
not only are they suffering from an
excess of negative emotion but they've
got no incentive movement forward
whatsoever okay so that's not an optimal
solution because it takes you out the
other possible and so I would call that
a nihilistic solution or a chaotic
solution it's not a solution it's a
dissolution and you could think about it
as a precursor to a potential solution
but it's very easy to get stuck there
and that's why Jonah could have stayed
in the belly of the whale along with all
the other people that were eaten by the
whale and never got back out and you see
people like that all the time their
error has come along blown out their
frames of reference they've collapsed
into the underworld into the chaotic
underworld and they don't know how to
get out
they have post-traumatic stress disorder
or they're depressed or they're hyper
anxious or or they're they're resentful
and aggressive and destructive like
there's any number of states of being
that can overwhelm you when the bottom
has fallen out of your life so it isn't
something that people are going to
it's not an optimal solution let's put
it that way well that the other that's a
nihilistic solution a collapse the other
solution is we're talking and I don't
get what I want from you and so I say
you'd better not do that again
I don't want to see that from you again
and so that's a tyrannical attitude
right what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take my universe of order and its
predictions and I'm going to say you go
along with this or I'm going to punish
you and that's that's a no there is a an
element in society like society is made
up of threats like that to some degree
it's an erratic level in erratic apart
of society that would be the tyrannical
aspect of the Greek King let's say you
know we've organized a set of
punishments and threats that keep each
of us in alignment however generally
speaking in a society that's functional
we've decided to adopt agreement with
that set of principles more or less
voluntarily we say well you have rights
and responsibilities and I have rights
and responsibilities and I'm willing to
pay a price for yours
including the acceptance of punishment
if I transgress but you're going to do
the same for me so there are there are
intelligent ways that punishment and
threat can be used and bounded so but it
that could easily degenerate into
tyranny and one of the methods that I
can choose to use if I don't want to
encounter error is just to enforce my
will on everyone else and I think when
that happens personally and in the
family and in the community and in the
state all at the same time then you get
the emergence of a tyranny and so I
would consider those two
counterproductive reactions to the
emergence of the unrealized world it's
like you say something I don't like I
collapse completely children don't like
other children who do that by the way
right it's something that's very
interesting to observe so let's say kids
have organized themselves to play a
little game of baseball with a plastic
bat in a ball and you know one child
pitches and the other child hits the
ball
the child catches it and puts the puts
the batter out and the batter bursts
into tears well what happens is the
other kids you know the first time that
happens they'll be sympathetic the third
time that happens they won't invite that
kid out to play baseball anymore so the
answer to we're not getting along is not
you get to burst into tears and and and
manifest extraordinary emotional
distress because if you do that no one's
going to want to play with you and
that's a lesson that many people could
stand learning again one of the things I
think that's really destabilizing our
society right now maybe is that I'm not
sure that kids have been encouraged or
allowed to play enough in the last 2530
years and I think a lot of this identity
stuff is actually fantasy play it's
delayed fantasy play because it's sort
of what you do when you're seven years
old it's like well I'm going to be this
identity that's what you're doing when
you pretend you're going to go along
with that because we're going to play
this out it's like that's fine you don't
impose that though right not not if
you're a kid that has a clue you invite
people to play you don't insist on your
identity and their compliance with it
it's not a playable game and you don't
burst into tears and run off when
someone won't play your game because
then they won't play with you and then
you have to turn to force and that's
that's fine if that's what you want to
do but you better look out because you
better be ready to use it those crazy me
were some morality come to responses
insurance applied in your city and will
thank you buy this if we can say
researcher a is better than this
structure being from a pragmatic
perspective does it come with responses
of making sure that people who are
trapped
perhaps the treadle restructuring
somewhere else that we have a
responsibility against good question I
mean that that's part of the question
that that I in some sense motivated in
some sense motivated the American
incursion into Iraq right so what's our
responsibility in relationship to
tyranny that's a good question all of
the increases of families are getting is
for non processing about the situation
of human and say solidarity
yeah you know I think that's I think
that criticism is more emerging because
of because it's apparently it's
apparently paradoxical and they've laid
out a set of principles to which in
principle they they adhere and one of
those principles is to reduce the
destructive power of the patriarchy it's
like okay there is some destructive
patriarchy for you radio silence
it's like hmm now what am I supposed to
do about that am I supposed to question
your adherence to those principles which
is exactly what should be done so I
think it's a it's it's a criticism of
performative contradiction you say
you're for this but when it comes to
acted out you don't selectively in this
situation so there's something wrong
there's something about your game that
you're not being straight about that's
the criticism and maybe there's
rejoinders to that you know well okay
okay well responsibility well you know
then you'd have to look at different
levels of analysis with regards to
interactions you definitely have a
responsibility to your partner and your
children okay so your responsibility to
your children as far as I'm concerned is
don't it's twofold one don't let your
children do anything that makes you
dislike them and there's a corollary to
that which is don't be an idiot
you know so that's partly why you need a
partner because your partner has to tell
you when your demands on your children
are
excessive because you're kind of you
know you're not 100% oriented properly
but still you're their target adult and
so it's up to you to help them choose a
path that makes you want them to be
around right and that that's your
critical responsibility and hopefully
you're enough of an an analog of the
broader community so that if they can
figure out how to get along with you it
radically increases the probability that
they'll be able to get along with
everyone so for example if you're
playing with your children two years old
you you help them you encourage them to
play in a manner that's fun and if you
get that down then you know when you
introduce them to another child don't
know how to play in a manner that's fun
and so great you've solved the problem
the problem is to get your child to
enter into the collaborative social
world and so yes you have a primary
responsibility for that and then with
regards to your partner here's something
to think about with regards to role so
my wife and I have had this discussion
many times and one of the discussions is
well how are we to treat each other in
public and it isn't her name is Tammy
the discussion isn't how should Jordon
treat Tammy in public or how should
Tammy treat Jordan that's not the
discussion this isn't personal
it's how should a wife treat her husband
and how should a husband treat his wife
it's impersonal and it's partly you
don't put your partner down in public
why well it's not because you're hurting
that person's feelings that's not why
it's that you're denigrating the
relationship that you are in voluntarily
you know I've some of the most painful
days I've ever spent one in particular I
spent with a group of men who had been
in therapy for their marriage and who
bloody well needed that I can tell you
that and they spent their whole day
complaining about their wives I could
just made me sweat the whole day I
thought I can't believe I'm here with
you guys that I can't tell you why I was
it's just you know it was just
happenstance more than anything and I
thought how can you be so damn dumb it's
like it's certainly possible that you
marriage barbaric married barbarian
witches fine you don't have you're so
lacking in sense that you would discuss
that in public not noticing that
you picked them so basically all you're
doing is holding up a sign and waving it
constantly that says I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot right and so well back to
responsibility you have a responsibility
to those whom you love and are obligated
to to ensure that they manifest
themselves in a manner that's most
beneficial to them over the long run now
you have the same responsibilities I
would say to yourself but you'll have
blind spots other people have to help
you with that but so the rule is you
know you don't let you don't you help
your wife figure out how not to make a
fool of herself in public and she
extends to you the same courtesy and
it's partly maintenance of the sacred
nature of the relationship it has
nothing to do with you or her precisely
it's broader and wider than that okay so
then that's two levels of responsibility
child partner next level of
responsibility you're asked at your
workplace to go uncut to undergo
unconscious bias retraining you say yes
it's like okay you've just admitted that
you're a bigot right because you're
acting about it's like I'm a racist
bigot obviously I need to be retrained
and so you might say well I'm not going
to make a fuss about it right or I've
been told to do it for maybe you agree
with it fine and if that if you agree
with it no problem you can make a case
for it I think it's a weak and appalling
case personally but you can make a case
for it you could say well you know why
I'm interested in my biases and how to
rectify them and like fair enough you
know people are biased but if you object
to it and you don't say anything then
you're complicit and then it's on you
and you know like a causes B and C and B
causes C and D and so forth the thing
tends does noise but it has this
tendency to expand and you'll come home
angry and upset and you'll go to the
training program and you'll think this
is ridiculous because that is what
you'll think in all likelihood and you
won't say anything
but it eats at you well
gated your responsibility and so and
then you might say well so then then
that's how the community becomes corrupt
that's how the community starts to be
corrupt is that people turn a blind eye
to emergent pathology when they know
it's pathological that's exactly what
the Egyptian story says Osiris is
overcome by Seth because he's willfully
blind willfully blind which means he
knows but refuses to he knows quote his
predator detection systems have gone off
monster well then you're supposed to
look okay exactly what sort of monster
is this what doesn't have wings it
doesn't have a tail you know you cut it
down into the you cut it from the
monster that it could be into the
monster that it is that's the first step
and then you take the appropriate steps
and then you also notice the other
monsters because here's something to
think about you're going to pay a price
for speaking up but you're going to pay
a price for not speaking up so it's like
monsters on the right monsters on the
left pick the ones you want to battle
with if you decide not to make your
stand you weaken yourself if you do it a
hundred times then even if the monster
was only this big now you're this big
it's going to eat you you know when it
was this big you probably could have
kicked it across the room it's too late
for that
you've capitulated and capitulated you
know and so what what you've done and
this is a way to think about it from a
union perspective this is what Jung was
trying to get at when he was talking
about Elka Elka me it's like the thing
that pops up to object to you is this
incredibly complex entity it's it's the
entire world encapsulated in the event
if you interact with it you unpack it
you differentiate your sense of the
world and you and you you gather new
skills so for example let's say there's
something going on at your workplace and
you need to object to it cuz it's
driving you crazy and you talk it over
with your wife so that you've got your
head screwed on straight say oh I've got
to say something and you go there and
you say something and you know you're
stumbling and awkward and all of that
but but you watch the response
and maybe you get what you're aiming at
maybe you don't but you've learned a
bunch you've learned while I noticed
coherent as I could be I'm not as good
at putting my arguments together
my boss is more of a son of a than
I that he thought it was this is a worse
problem that I knew about
it's like differentiated differentiated
so now the landscape is higher
resolution and so are you well so good
so maybe you're a little bit next better
prepared the next time you have to do
that and so the issue here to some
degree is don't lose an opportunity to
grapple with something that objects to
you especially when the object objection
is rather small because that's something
you can you say well I can put up with
it it's like fair enough like you don't
want to make everything into a war I
usually use a rule of three if we're
interacting and you do something that I
find disruptive I'll note it it's like
potential dragon go on and I'll leave it
be
and then if you do it again I think oh
yeah that probably wasn't merely
situation but I'll leave it be because
that's still not enough evidence but if
you do it a third time then I'll say hey
I just noticed this and you'll say no
that didn't happen and I'll say yeah not
only did it happen but it happened here
and it happened here and I'm not making
this up so there's something going on
here like I'm not ignoring it and we can
get to the bottom of it and then they'll
come up with a bunch of objections about
why that isn't necessary and you push
those aside and they'll come up with a
few more objections and they'll push
those aside and then usually they'll get
mad or burst into tears and if you push
that aside then you get to have a
conversation right and then you can
solve the problem but man it's you got
to be a monster because first of all you
need six arguments about why they're
objections aren't going to stop you and
then you have to not be intimidated by
the anger and you have to not be swamped
by compassion about the tears and then
you can have a conversation and people
don't do that they won't do that and so
they don't solve the problems and so
then the problems accrue right and if
they accrue over 15 years of a
relationship then that then they end up
fat ugly and in divorce court so and
that's you know that's not a
that's not a great outcome it's an it's
divorce court and cancer are similar in
their in their seriousness not always
but but sufficiently often so when that
error emerges it's a it's a glimmering
now you know we talked a lot about the
hierarchical structure of goals you know
and so here's something here's something
to think about so the thing that
announces itself is error has a two-fold
nature that's because it's chaos and
order at the same time or it's because
it's all the archetypal structures at
the same time it's dragon of chaos it's
the great mother positive and negative
it's the great father positive and
negative it's the individual hero and
adversary all of that manifests itself
in the moment of error right the
architects come forward did you make an
error because you're a bad person could
be now so so one of the things to think
about with regards to that is you know
in the Mesopotamian creation story when
when when time out comes flooding back
it's so interesting that story you think
about what she does
so she's the archetype of error let's
say the error that can take you out that
can dissolve you in salt water tears
well she's irritated because absolute
was destroyed so that the structure is
gone carelessness is destroyed the
structure up comes time at she's not
happy what does she do she prepares a
phalanx of monstrous monsters it's
exactly what the story says she produces
a whole horde of monsters to come at you
and she puts King you at their head and
Kenya was the king of the monsters and
later
so he's the ultimate bad guy he's Satan
for all intents and purposes in the
Mesopotamian version it's out of him
that Marduk makes human beings out of
his blood that Marduk makes human beings
that's a critical issue man
the Mesopotamian said imagine the worst
monster you can possibly imagine the
king of all the monsters that's the
blood of human beings Wow
so what does that mean well it means
that one of the
terrible things that lurks let's say
that you've been in a long-term
relationship and it collapses let's say
you were you know you had a tendency
towards alcoholism you weren't so great
with regards to your drug use you know
that conscientious and you had like four
or five kind of low-rent affairs and you
know it
your marriage collapses bang well who do
you first meet when you fall into chaos
you meet king of the monsters and he's
you it's like why did my marriage fall
apart what did I do wrong
bang bang bang bang I did all these
things well why because that thing
inhabits me what is it well that's the
most horrifying question well that's why
so down there in the archetypal space
all these things lurk the hero and the
adversary you've just met the adversary
right well maybe your tyrant that's
certainly possible maybe everything
around you was chaotic so what do you
encounter when things fall apart you
encounter the adversary you encounter
the tyrant you encounter the catastrophe
of nature and you encounter the dragon
of the chaos and they're all
intermingled you have to sort that out
that's what happens to Ellis when she
goes down the rabbit hole right she
meets the Red Queen and the Red Queen is
always running around off with their
heads off with her heads and she says in
my kingdom you have to run as fast as
you can just to stay in the same place
right down the rabbit hole you meet the
archetypes and so okay so back to
responsibilities well one of the things
Solzhenitsyn detailed we said well how
does societies go corrupt said it's easy
one
little sin at a time you go to work
someone's lording it over you you know
that they're tyrannical you don't have
the wherewithal to stand up it's like
okay you're a slave and so if you
continue to agree to be a slave you will
continue to generate tyrants right and
the only thing that can stop you from
doing that I think is the right kind of
terror
it's like careful what you give up
because that's this logos okay so so
alright that's this logos the logos is
the thing that enables you to mediate
between a between order and chaos and
maybe you have to have some faith in
that it's like well what should you do
if someone is harassing you well you
should fight back okay what is that
what's the most effective way to fight
back well sometimes it's physical but
that's not necessarily for the best
maybe it's through articulation maybe
it's through analysis right you want to
be sharp you want to be able to
decompose a problem you want to be able
to formulate an argument and a counter
response and maybe you want to be so
good at that that people don't mess with
you to begin with and then you're a
perfectly articulate counter monster and
you never have to take your sword out
that's that's the place that you want to
be it's like people should know after
three seconds of interacting with you
that harassing you would be a seriously
bad idea and then you'll have a
perfectly fine time with them so and
that's part of you know so there's some
utility in meeting the devil in the
underworld right because maybe he's got
something to teach you that's certainly
possible that and one of the things that
you can be taught is that your normative
morality which is basically your
harmlessness and your naivety
masquerading as virtue is completely
insufficient to protect you in the world
especially against the sorts of things
that you're talking about which are
tyrant tyranny tyrants will push until
you push back it's in their nature they
don't have internal controls so they
just push and push and push and push and
push and push even kids do that like
little kids do that all the time they'll
just push you until they hit that wall
they're actually quite happy when they
hit a wall because the last thing a
child wants is a universe without walls
it terrifies them right they want to see
while I'm in a swimming pool there's an
edge they don't want to see oh no this
isn't a swimming pool this is an ocean
I'm in the middle of an ocean I'm going
to drown that's a terrible thing for
children that's why they need discipline
and structure because it's consistency
and predictability and routine and all
the things that are extraordinarily
helpful to them okay so now think of
that hierarchy that we talked about so
you're not in a story you're in nested
stories and the nested stories round
themselves in action in actual embodied
action so if you're going to sit if
you're going to be a good partner maybe
you help prepare the meals and to help
prepare the meals means you pick up a
plate with your hand and you move it
physically through space and you put it
on the table that's where it stops being
an abstraction so at the bottom of an
ethical hierarchy of value are actions
not things that's the scientific world
but actions and then you can label the
actions with abstractions as you move up
the hierarchy so you're good at setting
the table so that means you're good at
making dinner so that means that you've
got one element of good being a good
partner in place and being a good
partner is one element of being a good
person and so you you're not so good at
setting the table and you say well I'm
not a good person it's like well no you
should go down to the higher resolution
levels of the hierarchy and start there
and that's what you do when you're
arguing with people but there's another
thing that's really useful about
conceptualizing the hierarchy in this
manner so so I think what we'll do is
we'll stop now for 10 minutes and all
because I want to bring up this diagram
because what I want to do next is it's a
bleak story at the moment because the
story is something like you're going to
lay out oversimplifications in the world
and they're going to be prone to
catastrophic error and then you have to
encounter what's terrifying in order to
progress and so what that means is that
progression is always dependent on
terror something like that and there's
some truth in that and that's why people
don't progress but it's not a sufficient
truth and I want to unpack that when we
come back so let's come back in 10
minutes and then I'll die can unpack
that there's this parable in the New
Testament that just came to mind I'm
going to mangle it a bit because it's
not one that I have well memorized but
and I'm probably going to conflate two
or three stories together but I think I
think I've got it right
Christ is walking down the road and
someone picks them up
the person is rich and and like well
wealthy and he has a talk they have a
talk and the wealthy man basically tells
him all the things that are wrong with
his life and then he asks him what he
should do about it and Chris says to him
you have to give up everything you own
and follow me
and that's often be read as a criticism
of wealth and that's actually not what
the story means what the story means is
this this guy has a lot of wealth but
he's still miserable and so that means
that what he has is the obstacle to what
he could be and so that's the message of
the story is that if you're miserable
with what you have then you have to let
go of what you have so that maybe you
could have something else and and so and
then there's some commentary on that
story I think other people are listening
and they say well if that's the price to
be paid then no one is ever going to pay
it and I think that's where the
statement it is easier for a man to go
through the eye of a needle for a camel
to go through an eye of the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to enter
paradise I believe that's the derivation
of that story and like I said that's
been read as a critique of wealth but it
isn't it's a critique of attachment now
you know in the Buddhist doctrine one of
the impediments to enlightenment is
attachment and people read that as
saying well you shouldn't care for
anything in the world and that's there's
a nihilism that's associated with that
and not and there is a strong nihilistic
tendency in Buddhism that has to do with
abandonment of the world do you see that
in Christianity to some degree with
people going off to lead ascetic lives
and to you know it's part of multiple
religious traditions that idea of
asceticism and there's some utility in
it if it is your attachment say to
material things or status or whatever
that's interfering with your
psychological progression now the idea
is that you should let go of whatever it
is that's interfering with your
psychological progression because no
matter how valuable what it is that's
interfering is
it's not as valuable as what you're
giving up okay however the criticism
still stands and the criticism was well
if the task is that difficult then no
one's going to do it and so in in the
Brothers Karamazov there's a famous
story called the Grand Inquisitor and
it's a story told by Ivan karamasoff
to his brother Elia and Ivan is a very
high-status
intelligent attractive tough minded
soldier and Alyosha is his younger
brother and he's kind of softer and less
rational more spiritual and also
training to be a no vitiate at the local
monastery and Ivan likes to tear strips
off it because he's a cynic and an
atheist and and and in Dostoyevsky's
normal brilliant manner he makes Ivan an
incredibly powerful articulate and
admirable character so when Dostoyevsky
wants to take someone on in his literary
investigations he doesn't take his enemy
and turn him into some sort of weak
puppet he takes his enemy and turns them
into the strongest possible enemy he can
imagine and then goes to battle against
that it's a hallmark of great literature
it's what distinguishes dusty SP for
example from Ain Rand because what ain't
Rand does is she takes her she's a
darling of the I would say libertarian /
right she takes her enemies and they're
all the same first of all every single
one of her negative characters is
exactly the same as every other one and
they're all bad you know there's there's
no redeeming qualities whatsoever in
them and they also I would say make
their weak characters who make weak
arguments that's not the way to progress
the way to progress is to take your
enemy seriously and to even inflate them
into something beyond their capacity to
inflate themselves and then see if you
can hammer out a solution to the genuine
problem that's being posed anyway so
dusty else he does that brilliantly
always and
what makes him so absolutely remarkable
but anyways I even tells le osha this
story he calls it the grand inquisitor
and that in the story Christ comes back
to earth in the Spanish Inquisition and
he's he's out by a fountain and people
sort of notice him and he starts
performing miracles and a big crowd
gathers around and it's like happy days
you know but then the Inquisitor shows
up this old you know harsh tyrannical
guy and he has his guards arrest him he
throws them in prison and so now Christ
is in prison and the Inquisitor comes
down and says to him while you're
probably wondering why which are you in
prison you know especially given that
were the members of the you know were
the representatives of the church that
you hypothetically found it and and
Christ remains silent through this
entire episode and the Inquisitor
basically says look you know you laid
down this ethic that it's wonderful but
it's superhuman no one can do it it's
asking way too much and so you're you
put the burden you put on people was
just far too great and so what we've
done in the Catholic Church in the
centuries since the church was founded
is was lightened the load we said well
we take ordinary people and say well
there here are some things you can do to
be a little bit better and you know
we've instituted confession and
repentance and all that we've kind of
toned it down so that the average person
has some hope of progress and we're
making headway and the last bloody thing
we need around here is you coming back
and like screwing up all our all our
good efforts is like it was nice to have
you around once but once was plenty man
we don't need you around anymore and so
Christ listens to this doesn't say
anything and then the Inquisitor turns
to leave and Christ grabs him and kisses
him on the lips and the Inquisitor turns
white and then leaves and when he leaves
the door he leaves the door open and
that's the end of the story and it's an
amazing story it's an absolutely
remarkable story in every possible way
and and you know Dostoevsky was
objecting to some degree to the tyranny
of the Catholic Church or even of the
Christian Church for that matter but the
thing that he did that was so damn
brilliant is that he even made the
Inquisitor leave the door open
no and as a Bellas critique of
Catholicism even during the Inquisition
it's so brilliant it's so emblematic of
Dostoyevsky's take on the world that he
criticized the inquisitorial aspect of
Christianity and of course it's the
tyrannical aspect of any belief system
but noted that they bloody well left the
door open
right so it's brilliant it's brilliant
it's it's it's remarkable so anyways the
whole point that I'm making here is that
there are terrible impediments to
enlightenment and the light is the
impediments are the necessity of
sacrifice and the necessity area of
necessity of the voluntary acceptance of
suffering I mean you see that in
Buddhism you know because one of the
canons of Buddhist one of the
fundamental principles of Buddhism is
that life is suffering and that
attachment makes it worse and well it
isn't it isn't precisely attachment its
attachment to things such that you
cannot release the things when it's time
to let them go right so like you're a
Phoenix you're a hundred years old your
feathers they're not working anymore
right you're all wrinkly you're done
it's time to burst into flames and be
reborn but you don't want to burn off
your feathers you want to cling to them
and that's not good because you have to
be willing to undergo that
transformation process and that involves
like you know if you if you take your PO
self apart because you've made a mistake
and you find out what it is about you
that's not set up properly and that's
why the mistake occurred that's really
going to happen for example when an
intimate relationship breaks down then
you have to be in a position where
you're willing to let the errors that
are part of your character that define
you right they might even be part of
your identity you have to let you have
to be willing to let them go you have to
be willing to let them burn off and
that's a hell of a thing to ask and so
then the question might be well is there
a less radical solution to the problem
then then then crucifixion and
resurrection or the total emulation and
regeneration because that's the
archetypal what's that's the archetypal
end point that if you want to put your
self together you have to die and be
reborn I mean that in that motif comes
up all the time
in in popular popular stories and in
mythology and so they here's here's how
I think that problem can be resolved so
let's go back to the Enochian story
momentarily so what happens and that the
Pinocchio story to me is analogous in
its structure to the Sermon on the Mount
so I'm going to make a parallel between
those two things so basically what the
Sermon on the Mount suggests is that you
should conceptualize the highest good
that you're capable of conceptualizing
and orient yourself towards that and
that having done that you should live in
the moment so it's not like you should
live in the moment it doesn't say that
because that's often Christ the hippie
you know so the hippies who have adopted
that or that that's sort of that that
element of Christianity say well you
live for the moment you know and and and
in meditation and other practices some
of the attempt is to get you to live in
the moment but you know just to tell
people to live in the moment it's like
what what the hell kind of advice is
that what about the future you know that
is not helpful advice somebody comes to
you and they're suffering dreadfully
because you know their mother has
Alzheimer's and they're unemployed well
live in the moment it's like that's just
not helpful it's it's and because it's
even worse than that it's judgmental you
say well the only reason you're
suffering is because you haven't
oriented yourself property to live in
the moment like no you're suffering
because your mother has Alzheimer's and
you don't have a job
it's like it's not because you aren't
living in the moment so living in the
moment isn't the right answer the right
answer is something more like orient
yourself towards the highest good that
you can imagine and then act in the
moment that's a whole different story
now that's what happens in the Pinocchio
story basically what happens is that
Geppetto sees the star beckoning in the
distance and he Orient's himself towards
the highest good he can imagine he wants
to take this creation of his and so this
is manifesting itself conceptually at
multiple levels simultaneously because
there's a there's a story about the
destiny of humanity in relationship to
God nested in the story it's like take
your fallible creation
your puppet and set up the pre set up
the condition such that it's capable of
taking on full functional independence
it's something like that so that's what
you do if you're a good parent with your
children you don't protect them you
don't offer them safety you don't do any
of that except insofar as it's necessary
to facilitate their development as fully
confident and courageous beings the
purpose of the protection is only to
allow that developmental process to to
continue so you you orient Geppetto
Orient's himself and so the farther
Orient's himself and then the son
undertakes the voyage and so alright so
let's say that that's the case you
orient yourself first then you can start
to rely on your then you can start to
concentrate more on your orientation to
the moment now I'm going to tell you
another story so you know I was just
watching Harry Potter the other day the
first one and I was watching the
Quidditch game and the Quidditch game is
very interesting because there's a game
and a meta game going on at the same
time so the game is just the standard
Quidditch game it's kind of like
basketball played on brooms right you
have to throw balls through hoops and if
you get enough points you win but at the
same time so there's the normal players
and then there's two seekers one from
each team and the Seekers aren't playing
the same game the game is nested inside
the seeker game actually because if
you're a seeker and you perform your
task that everyone wins right you win
but everyone wins and so you're not even
playing the normal game you're playing
the seeker game and the thing that that
that Harry Potter chases is this thing
called the snitch and the snitch this is
one of the things that's I can't I don't
know how the hell JK Rowling figured
this out I cannot figure it out because
that snitch is a winged ball right and
there's there's actually a symbol of
that winged ball called the round chaos
which Jung describes in his works on
alchemy and his works on healthy are
really really difficult it's not easy to
figure out what he's talking about at
all but the round chaos which is a
winged ball is it's it's a manifest a
of the spirit mercury and mercury is an
emissary of the God so you can think
about mercury uh the unconscious
manifesting itself in your in your field
of experience something like that in any
case the the round chaos is the
container of the primordial material
from which the world is made and I think
about it like this it's this thing there
it's that so when you encounter an
anomaly an error it's a container that's
a way of conceptualizing it and what is
it contained well it contains in some
sense it contains the whole world but
but here's an example like look let's
say God let's say that you've had
repeated fights with your wife about how
domestic duties are going to be arranged
among around meal time and you believe
me you're going to have those fights and
so and so what's happening is that
mealtimes are unpleasant because there's
a war for power going on in the kitchen
right and so then you think one day
while you're going to you know note that
and you're going to do an archeological
investigation and find out just what the
hell is going on and so you start
unpacking the fact that mealtimes are
not pleasant and so what's in that
little thing that you're unpacking that
package well the entire power dynamic
between men and women in the modern
world is inside that dispute and you
might find that part of the reason that
your wife is upset about the way that
mealtimes are arranged because is
because her grandmother was beat by her
grandfather and that's playing a role in
it played a role in determining her
unconscious expectations and that's
pathologizing one of the day to day
rituals in the house and if you're going
to unpack that you're going to have to
unpack all of that into you take a
little monster and you decompose it you
find out it's a Hydra it's got 50 heads
then you have to work through every
single one of those it's really really
difficult
so it's a container that contains
everything but the thing is if you
unpack it successfully let's say and you
deal with it you go see eight a
consensus then all of a sudden you get
you get peace say around your mealtimes
which is a major accomplishment man
because you have to eat three times a
day and it's the center of the household
and all of them so but the thing is is
that often when you're especially in the
context of an intimate relationship
things will emerge that produce
discontinuities and the question is what
should your attitude towards that
discontinuity be well you can punish the
person for manifesting the discontinuity
that's the tyrannical aspect or you can
let it take the whole thing apart and
that will happen I mean that's often how
relationships end is that a
discontinuity emerges and people get
into it and things go sideways so badly
that the whole relationship descends
into chaos and people bail out of it so
it's no wonder that people want to
ignore it and it's also no wonder that
they want to tyrannize it it's like quit
bothering me with that well possibly but
probably not and also if my attitude
towards you is quit bothering me with
that your attitude towards me when I
have the same sort of problem in Reverse
it's going to be exactly the same and so
we're not going to get anywhere with it
all right
but that still is painful now let's go
back to the Quidditch issue now here's
what happens is that Harry Potter is
picked to be the seeker so that means he
is the seeker whatever he represents is
the seeker and he's an interesting
character because he's touched by evil
and he's a rule breaker and he's also
kind of a normal kid he's not a hyper
intellect or anything like that that's
Hermione's rule right so he's normal but
but super normal at the same time and he
gets picked to be the seeker and and
then you think about what is it he seeks
and he seeks this thing that glimmers
rioted it flashes in front of him it's
made out of gold and it has wings and if
he grabs it then he wins and so the
question is what does that represent now
it's interesting that when
people watch that movie they actually
find that you know they think that
that's kind of cool that it's a cool
game and it is a cool game she laid it
out very nicely and the idea is that
well there's a game and if you play it
normally you win the game but in that
game is a meta game and if you play that
properly then not only do you win but
everybody wins so then the next rule is
the meta game supersedes the game and
that's the same idea that I'm chasing
here with you today about this meta
morality it's the it's the morality that
emerges as a consequence of the analysis
of a set of morality or it's the
morality
it's the morality to which other all
other morality should be subjugated
that's another way of thinking about it
and I said well that's a terrible thing
because it involves painful sacrifice or
maybe it involves confronting the thing
you least want to confront that's the
union dictum right if your life isn't
all that it should be then you should
find out the thing that you least want
to confront that you're avoiding and
confront that and that's the easy to say
but it's a terrible thing because it
means you're going to have to turn your
gaze to the place where you are weakest
and most vulnerable that is asking a lot
of people so then you might say well is
there an alternative and I think there
is an alternative so this is the anomaly
right this is the ball that contains
everything I think there is an
alternative I think it's associated with
this idea so imagine imagine we have a
we could have a conflict if we were in a
relationship we could have a conflict
that would blow the relationship apart
all right so we don't want to have that
conflict and then we could have no
conflict whatsoever which means that you
would never get to say what you wanted
and I would never get to say what I
wanted because we're either identical
which is just not happening or we're
going to have conflict because you're
going to want some things that I don't
want and vice-versa
so if there's no conflict we are not in
a relationship all right so zero
conflict is the wrong amount and
conflict it destroys the relationship is
the wrong amount and then you might say
well okay what's the optimal amount of
conflict well so so so then we can think
about how people respond emotionally so
let's say if you go after the person
that you're arguing with and you say
you're a bad person and you really make
that case you're bloody well hammered
home you remember 50 things they've done
that we're bad and you lay them out like
I'm going to stomp you you're a bad
person you really need to change okay
well first of all you're going to meet
tremendous resistance and that's like
you've got the hydrogen you bring in a
hydrogen bomb to the war right and maybe
unless you want to destroy everything
maybe that's not the most logical
solution but then by the same token
everything is alright and we never have
any conflict that's not helpful either
and you're going to get bored of that
and you're not going to develop and so
then the question is well maybe there's
some happy medium here maybe you want to
be repairing this structure you know the
structure that goes from micro actions
up to higher-order conceptualizations
maybe you want to be updating that on a
constant basis and you want to update it
in a manner that doesn't drop you into
chaos or place you in too much spaces
and then that answer is well how then
then the question is how is it that you
can calibrate your approach to error so
that you get the benefits of doing it
without the disadvantage of collapsing
into chaos and then the issue the answer
to that is something like it's something
like once you have decided to adopt
responsibility for being and will say
that what that means is that you have
conceptualized a good that you're
willing to devote yourself to and I
think you you're perfectly welcome to do
that on an individual basis I think you
should do it on an individual basis you
should consult with your ancestors while
you're doing that because generally
speaking the route to optimal the route
to to quality of life and productivity
has been laid out by other people we
kind of know what the parameters are you
need to do something that other people
find is useful and and and you have to
regard it as useful as well or at least
you have to be entertaining there has to
be something about you have value to
other people that you have to pursue
with a fair bit of diligence so you have
to play
a productive social role probably need
friends probably need an intimate
relationship and if it could be medium
to long term in for an intimate
relationship perhaps all the better
that's what most societies hold up as
ideal could assume well there's probably
a reason for that I think one of the
reasons is is that your life gets
fragmented otherwise badly fragmented
you know it's because every time you
have a long term relationship and it
fragments it's like your identity is
blown into pieces you get fragmented
across time it's it's not it's not good
it's it breaks you into pieces and you
don't necessarily recover that well it
makes everything much more in permanent
and unreliable all of those things so it
it introduces a tremendous amount of
uncertainty into your life and it also
means that you don't have anyone around
that you can really trust and that's bad
because if you have someone around you
can really trust and you have two brains
instead of one and like you probably
need two brains to manage your way
through life it's pretty complicated so
you orient yourself towards some good
the highest good that you can
conceptualize and it has to be through a
consultation with your ancestors because
you need to do the things that people
have always done and you need to do them
properly and you need to assume that
that's the way that you should live
unless you have a very good reason to
change it dramatically and maybe you do
but you got to start with some axiomatic
set of presuppositions because otherwise
you have to invent everything on your
own and you don't have enough time to do
that so you have to use normative
guidelines and if you don't then people
won't know what to do with you that's
another big problem if you live
completely outside the norm I mean you
know remarkable artists manage that to
some degree but of course they pay for
the privilege by being remarkable
artists so if there's something truly
remarkable about you perhaps you could
justify deviating from the normative
path but if there isn't first of all
there's nothing remarkable enough about
you to justify deviating in every way
from the normative path no matter how
remarkable you are so so that's part of
the the rescuing of the father from from
the depths is to reunite yourself with
the
structures of your community you can do
that in a way that you feel suits your
own needs best but I don't think you
cannot do it because it makes you weak
and then you'll drown all right so let's
say you have oriented yourself but not
perfectly because you're full of
mistakes and errors so then what do you
do because you have to fix those errors
but you still have to be oriented and
this is why I started getting to to get
interested in the phenomena of meaning
as a phenomenological experience to
experience something as meaningful it's
not exactly obvious what that means to
experience something is meaningful I
think that you can you can approach it
obliquely you know like if I said watch
yourself for two weeks and notice when
you're doing something that you regard
is meaningful I could say well here's
some here's some markers you lose a
sense of time you lose a sense of
vulnerability you're deeply engaged in
it it seems it seems worth the effort
right you forget yourself while you're
doing it maybe you forget your
existential concerns while you're doing
it you're not ruminating or obsessing
about the meaning of your life right so
so there's markers for it's like the
flow states that Csikszentmihalyi
described and then you can experience it
you experience it under certain sort of
ritualistic conditions you might
experience it when you go see a great
movie you might experience it when you
listen to music I think music is a very
very standard pathway for people to have
that kind of experience because
virtually everyone gets intimations of
mute of meaning from music and I think
music music is hierarchically structured
patterns that are representative of
being laying itself out properly it's
something like that so it's an abstract
representation of proper being and so we
can we can grapple with the phenomena of
music and we can we can Bach or
phenomena of meaning we can box it in a
little bit and start to conceptualize it
we can start to conceptualize it perhaps
as the manifestation of a deep instinct
and so I would say well meaning is what
NFS itself when you are when you've
oriented yourself properly and when
you've optimized the flow of information
between you and you between you and
chaos that might be the right way of
thinking about it because literally you
think about a piece of music because you
want it to be predictable but you don't
want it to be perfectly predictable you
want to be it to be predictable with
some interesting variations and
predictable with some variations that
make sense maybe you can conceptualize
that as something like this it's like
it's predictable at this order of
stability but it's it's varying down
here from time to time
and so you've got stable stability there
but variability there and you can handle
that so you want an overarching
structure of stability with some
internal variability and maybe that's
the way that you update yourself without
falling apart and then I would say you
can find the pathway to the optimal rate
of update by relying on your sense of
meaning that's what it's for what it
tells you is that you're you're
wandering your way through the world
between the catastrophes of chaos and
the catastrophes of order and now and
then you swing into the proper locale
you're where you should be and what
happens is you get engaged by that you
get meaningfully engaged by that and
it's fragile it'll move on you right
because it's very difficult to exist at
that point constantly your bad habits
all sorts of things your situation
there's all sorts of things that are
going to interfere with that but that
doesn't mean that that isn't where you
should be and so then you might say well
that's where you should strive to be all
the time and then the question might be
well what would it be like if you were
there all the time and I think that's
where intimations of paradise come from
I mean when words think it was
Wordsworth talked about intimations of
immortality and childhood people tend to
romanticize their childhood because of
the sense of intense engagement that
goes along with being a child and it's
one of the wonderful things about being
around children actually it's it's one
they pay you for their care and the way
the children pay you for their care is
that they turn normal things into magic
again when you're around them because
you've seen it a hundred times before
and so when you see it you don't see it
you see what you already know but when a
child sees it they don't because they
don't know they see it and then when you
watch them see it you see it too and so
it's just tremendous fun leading a small
child around to do things that you've
done before because they're sold you
know they're like this they're like all
the time and you know maybe that's too
much and they cry and they get upset and
all of that but a good part of the time
it's just wild-eyed wonder and then you
can see the world through their eyes and
it's payment and so that's that sense of
being engaged like that is something
that people love about children and
rightly so but it's also a marker to the
proper way of being you know there's a
dictum in the as a union idea that
there's no difference between the
archetype of the wise old man and the
archetype of the child they're the same
thing because the wise old man is the
person who found what he had in
childhood but lost right it said that's
a very powerful motif is that the
purpose of maturation is to return to
the state of childhood as a mature being
not to stay in the state of childhood
that's Peter Pan but to make the
sacrifice is necessary for maturation
and then return so well how do you do
that well you do that in part by noting
what it is that's meaningful you for you
to engage in I would say it's your
nervous system reporting to you right
hemisphere and left hemisphere balanced
that the balance between chaos and order
produces an output that says you are in
the right place it's a perception the
meaning is a perception of being in the
right place it's the genuine thing
however because it can be pathologized
that's the thing and that's why I think
there's a call to virtue in most great
religious traditions if you're going to
rely on your sense of meaning to orient
you you have to play a straight game
because otherwise you warp and twist the
inputs and then the mechanism won't
function properly you know it's like if
you if you were only if you're if you've
blinded yourself to half the world you
can't use your perception story and your
self properly because the half
the world that you're ignoring is going
to pop up at you unexpectedly and take
you down and so if your relationship
with the world isn't pristine honest
primarily then you can't rely on your
own internal orienting mechanisms and
then you either fall into chaos which is
an absolute catastrophe or you have to
rely on some kind of external Authority
and that makes you prone to possession
by tyrannical ideologies for example
which give you that sense of meaning
that you should in fact have as a
consequence of your own action but okay
so if if all relationships are our sort
of
predicated on of this balance between no
conflict and conflict that destruct that
if we will look if we were to look at
this at a more macro level we see this
sort of matte effect in in history in
our world like with conflict in between
countries in the two systems ideology
etc but what is this sort of navigation
between the exact line of no
consequences conflicts how does that not
imply that some people are inherently
due to chaos it might imply that you
know what are the things so look so
sometimes sometimes you don't have an
answer that works you can answer that
produces the highest probability of
success and like I could view the
archetypal world from a religious
perspective and say that there's such a
thing as ultimate and final Redemption
that's a metaphysical claim I don't I
don't want to do that I think it's
independent of what I'm talking about
what I'm saying is that there's an
archetypal path that's laid out in in
the mythology of the hero and it's your
best bet that's all it's your best bet
it doesn't mean that if you apply it
that everything is going to turn out the
way you might want it to turn out but
but I would say this there's a way of
there's an interesting twist on that too
this is one of the things that I came to
understand about trying to speak the
truth is that you can make an assumption
you can make a fundamental assumption
based on your ignorance let's say and
the in eradicable quality of your
ignorance but you can't compute the best
possible outcome what you can do instead
is make a decision and one decision is
well I'm going to say what I think and
see what happens and then you can define
that as the best possible outcome now
you might say well now and then that's
going to lead you into chaos it's like
yeah it is it is it's a strange
it's a strange inversion but regardless
of all doubt I would still say
human beings are finite and limited and
mortal you know and death is final
let's say I'm not saying that but we
could easily say that doesn't matter
this is still the best pathway forward
it isn't certainty there's no certainty
and it's very frequently in life you
have poison a or poison B like you get
to pick your poison you don't get to
pick the elixir of life but I would but
I would say I would also say I don't
think there's any reason to be
particularly pessimistic because we
don't know what would happen if people
really tried hard to get their acts
together like if they understood the
necessity of that and really put it
forward I mean I mean I've had lots of
experience with my clinical clients now
you know I've seen dozens and dozens of
people and we have tried jointly to get
their lives straighter and it works
almost inevitably now that doesn't mean
I've had clients who died you know we
were three-quarters through a wonderful
process of psychological renovation and
they got cancer and died so so there's
there's no certainty associated with
this but it's the best solution
available and and it's also possible
that it's a good enough solution now I
was talking to my class yesterday about
this you know so you if you pursue the
things in your life that are meaningful
once you've oriented yourself and that
means accepting the challenges that come
along with that because one of the
things that you'll find you even find
this in music if you know a piece of
music completely then you can not want
to listen to it anymore this still has
to be some challenge in it you still
have to track it and sometimes music is
so complex you just can't it just sounds
like noise modern music is often like
that because it's so well it tends
towards the chaotic and so it's I find
it difficult to listen to because I
can't get a handle on it but then you
know so it's too challenging and then
there's other music pop music is often
like this it's catchy the first two
times you hear it then you never want to
hear it again it's too much there's too
much predictability and not enough chaos
and hopefully you find a piece of music
that's somewhere in the middle you can
listen to it 50 or 100 times and each
time you listen to it there's still some
new nuance in it that you didn't that
you didn't expect before and so well you
kind of want to set up your life like
that
so that
and I think you see that the phenomena
of meaning manifests itself at the area
at the locale of optimal challenge so if
the thing so one of the things for
example or might say well let's say you
want to set some goals for yourself we
say well they're remarkable goals but
they're all there to unattainable you're
just going to find it frustrating to
pursue them it's going to be too
punishing and then we might say well
here's a goal and you think well I could
do that you know standing on my head
there's nothing in it well both of those
two extremes are going to leave you in a
state that isn't characterized by the
optimization of engagement and meaning
one is too difficult too punishing it's
the judge and nothing else and the other
is the ultimate and merciful mothers
it's like you win no matter how you play
so then you calibrate and say well you
know I need I'm I'm up for a challenge
at this level I wouldn't recommend that
because that's just a bit like people do
that you want it might want to
investigate your character in detail and
decide you know what's going on at this
level of analysis that's pretty harsh
but you can certainly continually retool
yourself at more micro levels and that
and I think what you do is you pick the
level of retooling that optimizes your
willingness to be engaged in it and then
what's so interesting about that is that
I think is that you get the benefits of
perfection so to speak while still being
imperfect the imperfect your actual
imperfection has nothing to do with it
what's relevant is the jerk is the
journey that you're undertaking to
rectify the imperfection so instead of
aiming to be the entity without flaws
you're aiming to be the entity that
continues to realize its flaws and
overcome them well that's a game you can
play forever and that's maybe the
ultimate in being an unplowed entity
it's something like that so so I want to
show you some pictures that I think are
associated with that so this one to
begin with this is an absolutely amazing
picture I think so this is Bert hold
firt Meier Tree of Life flanked by Eve
and Mary ecclesia
and this in some sense this this picture
summarizes the biblical stories in one
picture which is that's pretty amazing
that that a picture can do that and so
let me explain the picture a little bit
so the first thing you see here is that
this is the tree this is the Tree of
Life and so it echoes the tree of the of
the knowledge of good and evil but this
is post-fall so we interpreted the story
of Adam and Eve already is that human
beings became self conscious they
discovered death they discovered
morality it was all a consequence of
interacting with the fruit and the snake
something like that and you can read
that as an as an evolutionary tale you
can at least read it as a representation
of the emergence of self-consciousness
in human beings so what does that mean
well it means that the Apple in some
sense was equivalent to death and that's
what you see here you see Eve is picking
fruit from the tree here but the fruit
is it's on the skull side of the tree
and so Eve it's the vulnerability of Eve
she's naked there and displayed to the
world it's the vulnerability of Eve
that's one way of thinking about it was
the vulnerability of Eve that was the
catalyst to the development of human
self-consciousness and I think that
that's true it seems to me to be a
reasonable proposition and so Eve Eve's
relationship with the fruit and the
snake doomed human beings to the
realization of mortality that's what
this side of the picture represents and
so it's a catastrophe
and it's associated with here with the
snake in the fruit it's human beings
attempts to understand how it is that
they emerged into a self-conscious world
okay so fine so that's on this is on the
the fall end of the story and this is on
the solution end of the story now what
you see here in there's a skull there
and there's a crucifix here and you see
there's all these little fruits on this
tree so it's the apple of death that Eve
is handing out on this side and it's the
host that plays a role in the
cannibalistic right that's at the center
of Christian ritual that Mary as the
church is handing out as a medication
for
yes so she's handing out the antidote
well what's the antidote well it's a
strange thing it's associated with this
crucifix and that's translated into this
wheat and host so you're supposed to eat
that and that that is the incorporation
of whatever this represents well the
question then is what does that
represent it to assist it's a symbol of
suffering obviously it's a symbol of the
ultimate in suffering it's the weirdest
thing because the picture proposes that
to ingest the ultimate in suffering is
to simultaneously ingest the antidote to
the catastrophe of the knowledge of
death it's a very strange paradox but
but it's the it's the proper paradox
it's at the center of this of the great
drama that's represented by this picture
a little knowledge of death destroys you
full voluntary acceptance of it is the
Cure that's the idea well that's a
that's a hell of an idea it's not only
to and to accept it is simultaneously in
some sense to take responsibility for it
because you don't take responsibility
for things that you don't accept you
only take responsibility for things that
you do accept say well the world is
fundamentally flawed because it's
fundamental nature is vulnerability
intolerable vulnerability I'm not going
to take any responsibility for that but
that's really Kane's attitude in the in
the story of Cain and Abel he
externalizes responsibility for the
catastrophe of his life and therefore he
doesn't make the right sacrifices and so
the paradoxical injunction here is
accept responsibility for the
catastrophe of your life and that way
you transcend it simultaneously and
there's a there's an unbelievably
hopeful message in there and the message
is you're actually strong enough to do
that you just don't know it and you
won't find out till you do it you can't
find out till you do it
but if you did it you'd find out that it
was true it's a massive risk it's the
ultimate in risks right you have to be
willing to lose your life in order to
find it it's like exactly right so that
picture when I started to understand
that picture look every time I look at
it just blows me away I can't
unbelievably it's an unbelievably
sophisticated set of ideas but I don't
think it's much different really than
this idea
I mean Buddha finds his enlightenment
under a tree it's not fluke that that's
the case that's his natural environment
and he's sitting in that Lotus here the
Lotus opens up it's a this thing that
springs up from the depths he sits there
illuminated the same way he's got a halo
that's the Sun that stands for higher
consciousness and he's transcended by
accepting the fact that life is
suffering
he's transcended the limitations that
are part of mortality you see that
symbol there that swastika you see it
there it's reversed the Nazis reversed
it well think about that I mean they
weren't stupid
as symbolism they're symbols had meaning
is what the swastika were represented
was what this represents reversed well
that's a very bad idea this is the thing
that this this idea is what enables
people to transcend their suffering and
Buddha said well don't don't be too
attached to things and what does that
mean it doesn't mean deny the world it
might mean deny the world if you're too
in love with the material like with
material well-being let's say then your
pathway to transcendence and meaning
might be to abandon that because it's
it's constraining you it's making you
less than you could be but the
fundamental lesson the more fundamental
lesson that's underneath that is don't
let what you are stop you from being
what you could be right and so then the
question is well what do you identify
with do you identify with what you are
then your tyrant you identify with with
chaos because that's the opposite of
order say
then you're nihilistic well you don't
identify with either of those you know
that they're both necessary you know
that you have to live with both of them
but you would you identify with the
capacity to continually transcend what
you are and then you seek out error
that's what humility is like I'm error
ridden it's like so I want to see I want
to put myself in the situation where I
can discover one of my errors hopefully
not in a way that's going to knock me
completely out of the game right I want
to I want to seek out a challenge I want
to find out where my limits are I want
to find out where there's not enough of
me yet and I want to do that in a way
that's engaging because you know you can
wear yourself out fighting dragons
obviously you can exhaust yourself
completely and that's not helpful you
know what one of the things I learned
for example when I was coaching when I
was coaching warriors who these were
people who had very high-end careers and
so they had an infinite workload no
matter how much they worked flat-out
there was always way more work that they
should do it's very difficult thing to
learn to manage and so they were
exhausting themselves and I said well
you know you have to work less per day
it's like well no that's not happening I
can't do that and so what I learned over
time was ok so this is what you have to
do every three months you have to block
off 4 days and go have a vacation you
have to plan that in advance so it's in
your calendar so that your secretary
doesn't book your time and then you need
that because you have to recuperate
enough so that you can work as hard as
you're going to work and of course they
were nervous about that and I said well
look we can we can calibrate this let's
keep track of your billable hours over
the next year and see if they increase
or decrease because I bet you if you
take more time off you'll actually have
more billable hours you'll actually have
your cake and eat it too you'll get to
have a vacation and you'll be more
productive and that inevitably that was
what happened and so that's a matter of
calibrating the game properly right you
want to play a game that you can play
today but also one that you can play
next week and next month we're not
talking about you know your your career
this week we're talking about you having
a career that lasts 30 years that
doesn't kill you that doesn't make you
hate yourself or the job that doesn't
make you better that doesn't wear you to
a frazzle so it has to be optimized and
so I think that you can
fact decide to take on the load that's
optimally meaningful if you want and
then you get to have your cake and eat
it too you're on the pathway to
continual incremental improvement you
only have to burn off a feather at a
time instead of having the whole bloody
thing burst into flames but it's a
constant it's a constant source of
renewal and there's an idea that to be
renewed you have to drink the water of
life right that's an old mythological
idea and what's the water the water of
life chaos is water water water is chaos
water is what washes away too much order
and to stay continually let's say
refreshed by the water of life is to
take on exactly the right amount of
chaos to make sure that your garden is
properly nourished and I think meaning
is actually the marker of that and and
as I said you know that I'm not I
wouldn't consider myself either naive or
particularly optimistic person I don't
think I'm either of those but this is an
actually an idea this is one of the only
ideas that I've ever found that I really
believed to be rock-solid I actually
think that it's true
and it's very optimistic because it says
you can use your sense of meaning to
calibrate your progress through life it
but there's rules you have to aim at the
highest possible good that you can
conceive now in that subject update
because what the hell you know but you
start by aiming at the star you can see
rather than the dimmer one that you
can't yet perceive and then you decide
that you're going to do that honestly
right there's that that's a big decision
so the first decision I think in some
sense is a decision of love you're going
to decide that being is worthwhile and
that you're going to work for its
betterment and that's a decision that's
based on love and the second decision is
based on truth having made that decision
you're going to play a straight game
having made those two decisions I think
that you can allow your sense of meaning
to calibrate your pathway and then
what's so interesting is that you hit a
state that's as close to paradise unless
you're going to hit right away because
being engaged like that it's better to
be engaged in the solution of a complex
problem than not to have a problem at
all and that's that's no different than
saying it's better for there to be being
that non-being because being is a
problem
and so if you want to have no problems
then you have no being and you could say
well being is so miserable that maybe
that's the route we should take and fair
enough but maybe you can have your cake
and eat it too
you can have the damn problem it could
be a problem we're solving and you can
be so engaged in solving the problem
that it justifies the fact that the
problem exists and then you get then you
get to have you get to have the problem
and the solution at the same time and
maybe that's better than not having the
problem at all and I believe that
because one of the things I have seen
and I've seen this so interesting being
so interesting when I'd be lecturing to
people especially more recently and and
this is also manifested on you itself on
YouTube I'm talking to people a lot
about responsibility and it's young men
in particular that seem to be responding
to that and I think that's partly
because I think that young women in some
sense have their responsibility map
already laid out for them it's also less
voluntary in some sense for women
because they have more complicated
problems to solve in the first part of
their life right because they have to
get the family problem solved but
whatever
I've been talking very in a very
delineate 'add matter about
responsibility which is a strange thing
to sell to people but responsibility is
what gives your life meaning and so then
you might say well then take on ultimate
responsibility and what happens you have
an ultimately meaningful life and then
you might say well if your life is
ultimately meaningful doesn't matter if
it's punctuated by tragedy or even
predicated on tragedy it's worth it and
I think that's true and everything I've
seen indicates to me that's true every
time I get my clients to take on more
responsibilities you know it and it
isn't an injunction you're a bad person
you should take on responsibility have
nothing to do with that you can define
the damn responsibility it isn't
something that that someone else should
impose on you it's not a matter of doing
what you should do in some abstract
manner it's not that it's the choice of
what game you're going to play and you
know you can play the game of the seeker
I would say and if you play that game
then everyone wins and it's the best
game you can play and so the the answer
in some sense to the tragedy of life to
the catastrophe of life to the fall is
to adore
the responsibility of mortality that
goes along with that and to play that
game maximally and paradoxically it's in
the willingness to do that that the
solution emerges and I don't you know I
have done my best with every single
thing I've talked to you guys about I
have done my best to do what does TSD
does in his novels which is I make a
proposition and then I spend months or
years trying to figure out if I can take
the bloody thing apart if there's
something wrong with it because I want
to find out I want to hit it with a
hammer and see if it breaks and what
I've been trying to do is to tell you
all the things that I've gathered let's
say or laid out or articulated or
discovered over the last thirty years
that I have not been able to break with
the biggest hammer that I could take to
them and I guess that's the fundamental
one is that I believe that the the the
idea that lurks in these images derived
from very different cultures it's the
same idea life is suffering right
indisputable what do you do about that
you you voluntarily accept it and then
strive to overcome the suffering that's
a consequence of that and you do that
for you and you do that in a way that
makes it better for other people and
then that works and one question might
be well how well does it work and the
answer is you the only way that you can
find out is by trying it that's it
that's the essential element of it the
proof is to be derived by the
incarnation of the attitude in your own
life no one can tell you how it will
work for you it's the thing that your
destiny is to discover that and you have
to make you have to make the decisions
to begin with it's like because you
can't do this without commitment you
have to commit to it first that's the
act of faith that the Kierkegaard was so
insistent upon you have to say I'm going
to act as if being is good I'm going to
act as if truth is the pathway to
enlightenment I'm going to act as if I
should pursue the deepest
meaning possible in my life and there's
reasons to do none of those they're real
reasons so it's really a decision but
you can't find out what the consequence
of the decision is unless you make the
decision I think the same thing happens
when you get married by the way so if
you think you might leave you're not
married and then you think well the
marriage didn't succeed it's like well
maybe you were never married because the
rule is you don't get to leave and
there's a reason for that rule now I'm
not saying that there aren't situations
where there should be exceptions made
for that that's not the point the point
is that there's some games you don't get
to play unless you're all-in and the
other thing that's so interesting about
being alive is that you're all-in
no matter what you do you're all-in
this is going to kill you so I think you
might as well play the most magnificent
game you can while you're waiting
because do you have anything better to
do really why not pick the best thing
possible that you could do why not do
that maybe you could justify your
wretched existence to yourself that way
I think you could that's what it looks
like
you know people find such meaning in the
responsibilities they adopt it stops
making them ask questions about what
life is for if you have a newborn child
for example like unless you're really in
a bad way psychotically depressed or
maybe your personality really needs some
retooling you stop thinking about
anything but ensuring that that baby is
doing well and if someone comes along
and asks you an existential question
about your commitment to that the right
response is why are you asking me such
stupid questions when when when this
this is manifesting itself right in
front of your eyes like how blind can
you be that isn't a time for for
questions about the meaning of life the
answer is right in front of you and if
you can't see it it's not because life
has no meaning it's because you're blind
I mean that's what the image of the
Virgin Mother and the child is all about
it's like what's the answer to the
meaning of life here's an answer it's
like well I'm going to criticize that
well go right ahead
you know it's like it's like what you're
like a you like a what do you call that
a termite going on a temple there's no
there's no utility in that sort of
criticism you're it's blindness and it's
the same thing with regards to the path
of the hero it's like it glistens in
front of you and you can criticize it
it's like fine put the cart before the
horse and and see how far you get so I
thought to bring full closure to the
class I was trying to solve this
terrible puzzle that confronted me for
and many other people about how it was
that human beings got themselves in such
a tangle about what they believed such a
tangle that we were pointing the
ultimate weapons of destruction at one
another which by the way we are still
doing I thought okay well I understand
that we need their belief systems they
orient us and that means there will be
conflict between belief systems and that
can be a catastrophe and that's being
played out everywhere again in very many
ways what's the solution to that well
one possibility is there's no solution
it's just mayhem all the way around
could be the case but it seemed to me as
I delved into it that the proper
solution to that was to live properly as
an individual because you're more
powerful than you think way more
powerful than you think I mean god only
knows what you are in the final analysis
you're blind to your own weaknesses but
you're also blind to your own strengths
and so then I think well if you've got
your act together it'd be better for you
and instantly it would be better for
your family assuming they wanted you to
get your act together and not everyone
does but and then it would be better for
the community it's like how far could
you take that if you stopped wasting
time and if you stopped lying and if you
oriented yourself to to the highest
possible good that you could conceive of
and you committed to that how much good
could you do well I would say might find
out
so that's what I think you should do you
should find out you don't have anything
better to do and there's nothing in it
as far as I've been able to tell there's
nothing in it but good so maybe you
could sort yourself out so that you
wanted nothing but the good and and then
maybe you could help make that manifest
in the world and maybe we wouldn't have
all these terrible problems then at
least we'd have fewer of them and that
would be a start so it's it's that the
answer to the problem of humanity is
that is the is the integrity of the
individual that's the answer so and
states that are predicated on that
realization are healthy so in states
that aren't are doomed to stagnation and
catastrophic collapse and personalities
that are predicated on self tyranny and
the tyranny of others are doomed and
doomed to collapse so and then you think
well what's the barrier the barriers are
you willing to accept the responsibility
and part of the answer to that is reduce
the dam responsibility until it's
tolerable you don't have to fix
everything at once you could just start
by fixing the things that you could fix
or you could even do it more you can do
it with even less self-sacrifice you
could start by fixing only the things
that you want to fix God you can get a
massive way that way so do it see what
happens that's what you should have been
talking University right from the
beginning it's like a Mathias good tool
yourself into something that can attain
it and go out there and manifest it in
the world and everything that everything
that comes your way will be everything
that comes your way will be a blessing
and so all you have to do is give up
your resentment and your hatred I know
that's a hard thing to give up because
you have plenty of reason for it
that's probably a good place to stop
so to the pleasure
[Applause]